після того, як нідерланди на референдумі
сказав і не
відході про асоціацію між україною цієї с
прем'єр україни марк юти шукаю випаду
стіни та делікатної ситуації коли та
український євроінтеграції на рубля хоче
ти палицею біля колеса і думку владних
вибір тефни може і нувот і так взяв і
вся компромісний документ за точно не
вода біля води про асоціацію який
нідерланди хоче ви нас ти на у-2
jeunesse все от і дня до вплинуло
що скликаю точно не від сочі через
шкодити ван і подалі євроінтеграції
України
нідерланди не хоче шо п'єш гаранту вов
колективно б спайку весь кого
допомогу Україні оліфу воді про
асоціацію процесу нерідко на тому місці
позбавляючи завальний слова опитування при я не
помру
діалог і з перу бітність вау за зовнішньою
і бас такий політати і
то ви дуже а потенціалу веселу і
технічно успіх брати та нідерланди бояться
що про суть я тебе може заподіяти масу
виллю міграцій українців dujos у тому
числі змотую процесу що ваня у team
село в моді так уже не знаєте тут лише
оповідання вночі українські супротивники
кожен буде їх інших не можна до
screamin' вати написали їх не огром
агенство
а їх не доступ на європейський ринок
протий у роті і спілкуватися можна його
пофарбують і
нідерланди не хоче рахунок їсти куди є
україна порохова в мисці гуртувало
української раху нки у team у у гоги
процес і знайдіть чути про фінансову
допомогу виключено на потойбічників пити
вах так як ідея зарічну повторив
євросоюзу
адже шили до молдови без того за долю
у роботі європейських агенціях їх зуби
в'язаний гуртувати в низькій теж ви
могли прем'єр-міністра маргарет ще до а
суть оффе ціни до українських
інтересів а раніше інструмент за
спокійніше владних вибір тиф дикий на
референдумі
на 3 загартованих думав і не політику з
with heel або про сутність атіус україну you a
tex самої води mozilla хитайся у зраді
рада gti